summer is in full swing which means so
are all the bugs and the bugs love me
they like really love me they numb me to
the Bone here with some tips to keep the
bugs at Bay is someone who's anything
but a pest he's my dear friend Danny
Theo hi
thank you everybody loves you every
being loves you but like bugs are like a
real issue for me like I'm on vacation
but I have to find myself like at a
doctor's office they just find me so
delicious I've been single for seven
years but I can't keep the bugs away
well let's um you know let's be smart
about eliminating the ones that you
don't want okay okay this one I'm super
excited about this is our first tip
because the Drew Barrymore show has
teamed up with Zevo today and for good
reason pesky bugs are a huge problem for
almost everyone like you in the Summer
from leaving seasonal fruit on the
counter to kids leaving the house with
doors left open we all deal with them
right so there is an easy effortless
solution to help get rid of bugs in your
home Zevo flying insect traps attracts
flying insects like house flies fruit
flies gnats and reduces and eliminates
them in a way that's worry free for
homes with kids and pets the Trap
attracts insects with blue and you V
light with no odor or mess and captures
them on a discreet sticky pad that you
never have to touch check it every week
or so to see all of the bugs you've
caught it went full just toss the
cartridge and put in a fresh one will
this work what are you doing
well now I'm ready for summer I just
need to run an extension cord up here um
oh yeah you do got to plug it in right
it needs the it's the UV light that
really makes it work well this is the
level of protection I need Danny this
this might be a new invention I feel a
jewelry line coming on if the Zevo
people are listening I need this kind of
protection in my life what's next okay
so here's the other thing guys a lot of
us love to use starch when it comes on
making crisp shirts but the problem with
starch it's also starches bread starches
pasta starches mashed potatoes so when
you use spray starch under clothes it
attracts bugs because basically it's a
food source for them so no more spray
starch okay eliminate that all together
just use a really smart iron with the
steam function to get your clothes
really crisp and then for sweaters and
things that you're not using just put it
in an airtight container and then you
don't need moth balls you don't need any
chemicals this is just a more
intelligent way of storing things and
then it stays fresh I never would have
thought of that I know the starch
but I am predominantly starved and if
they love starch this might make sense
okay next okay so this is a container of
what do you think I think it looks like
Oreo cookies it kind of does we give it
a smell oh whoa coffee coffee grounds so
save your used coffee grounds because
there's a study done where you put
coffee on sprinkle on top of an ant hill
they all ran away they hated the smell
so we're not saying you do that what we
say is go around the perimeter of your
home and just take tons of coffee guards
and sprinkle them in because it looks
like dirt it'll blend right in and
you've basically created a coffee force
field that is so cool to keep ants out
no I'm not kidding right
because all I eat is pasta I don't have
a Zebo and
okay I'm going out I'm immediately gonna
sprinkle coffee I'm certainly following
the no starch on the outside and I'm
getting a Zevo for the inside there we
go problem solving problem solved
summer
thank you we'll be right back
[Applause]
[Music]